après avoir traversé la planète pour
visiter les états unis d'amérique puis
découvrir la culture japonaise de
l'autre côté du globe
cyprien a décidé d'assouvir sa soif de
culture étrangère en allant en espagne
or pour savoir que moi là bas je suis
pas trop prédestiné à visiter l'espagne
j'ai fait neuf années d'allemands élevé
autant dire que cela m'a servi
absolument à rien là bas qu'elle sait
comme elle a une grosse carte au mobile
et de lèche mario kart hoeven wichegrod
gothard pettitte a rien j'ai un petit
peu préparé mon séjour en espagne j'ai
même appris un petit peu d'espagnol
pendant plusieurs semaines et tout est
bien sûr j'ai commencé par barcelone et
bien sûr à barcelone on parle catalan el
català espagne là je m'étais tellement
préparé j'étais d'aig et bien sûr les
barcelonais se font un malin plaisir à
te corriger tout le temps une sandwichs
des ramones fait vendre des paniers de
ramon fait les pas des ramones des
vannes et d'ailleurs aux arcs à
barcelone la majorité des touristes
français je sais de quoi je parle à
moi-même je viens de france il ya un
truc incroyable que j'ai pu entendre de
la bouche de plusieurs pensées là bas et
si on est le parc guell après encore des
français ils sont partout et toi tu es
quoi tu vient d'une autre planète
peut-être tu es un extraterrestre c'est
ça bah oui c'est simple il ya tellement
de français à barcelone que je suis
tombé sur des serveurs français ou une
sandwich d'épargné c'est un sandwich au
jambon des béni oui oui
aujourd'hui échouage de haixi cameroun
ça c'est de la demande et ben voilà j'ai
perdu mon catalan je suis tellement nul
en espagnol que je me suis tapé la honte
de ma vie là-bas on était en voiture
avec des potes c'est bizarre il n'ya pas
salida dans le routard pourtant sa
indiqué mme bardou
telle karine à voir dans cette ville
salida ça veut dire sortie en espagnol
ah ouais ouais je savais je savais bien
une des différences avec la france et
notamment les horaires des magasins
puisque tous les petits commerces
ferment entre 13h et 16h et là je me
suis dit pas lequel
et puis je me suis promené l'été en
andalousie à 14h et là tout est expliqué
chaleur extrême alto qu'alors il faisait
tellement chaud que quand je sortais je
me collais contre les murs pour
bénéficier de 15 cm dhombres aux
convives à ces jolies andalousie aux
coups de soleil
après j'ai pas me plaindre du beau temps
ça c'est sûr d'ailleurs il ya un truc
que je peux pas m'empêcher de faire dès
que je bouge à l'étranger ou dans le sud
de la france c'est que je regarde la
météo à paris et plus il fait moche là
bas plus je kiffe l'homme le plus fort
de france et à linverse ce qui m'énerve
grave salut cyprien alors c'est bien
l'espagne ici à paris il fait super beau
un des trucs que j'ai préféré en espagne
c'est la nourriture et un truc qui m'a
étonné c'est qu'en fait ils font des
boîtes de conserve de qualité genre
s'est reconnue et tous et il ya même des
bars à tapas qui te serves d'état parce
qu'ils sortent de conserve
c'est comme ça faut s'y faire je vais
vous prendre des patatas bravas ce et
des artichauts
c'est d'accord en fait c'est ça c'est
waouh vous êtes cuisinier vous aussi si
vous avez fait top chef non si c'est
vous thierry marx si c'est vous
ghislaine arabian
vous êtes ghislaine arabian c'est ça si
bref l'espagne c'est mortel j'ai adoré
la nature manger la culture manger les
espagnols manger et que mon dieu en
espagne au feeder 0 ça c'est de
l'allemande
nerb